[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast and these are our top stories
hope amongst the horror humanitarian aid
will arrive in the besieged city of
mario paul later as president zielinski
says nearly
000 ukrainians were evacuated from
across the country on saturday
new satellite images show the widespread
destruction across mariopol as russia
intensifies shelling in the area
the ukrainian parliament claims that
russia has installed a new mayor in the
city of molitopol 24 hours after saying
the previous one was kidnapped
it comes as president zielinski suggests
that russia is trying to carry out
similar changes in occupied carson
all this as the net closes on the
capital kia we're with the people
desperately trying to escape the russian
attacks
helping to provide a home the government
will give 350 pounds to uk households
that take in ukrainian refugees
and in a quarter too we'll take another
run through the papers with the
broadcaster pete price and the author
and broadcaster emma wolfe
[Music]
morning oh and we begin this seven
o'clock hour with that breaking news the
ministry of defence have posted their
daily well usual defense intelligence
update out of ukraine this morning let's
take a quick look at what they are
saying
certainly a focus on what has happened
before russian forces attempting to
envelop ukrainian forces in the east of
the country
the update provides
as they advance from the direction of
karkiv in the north mario paul also of
course in the south
uh those forces advancing from crimea uh
well the intelligence update tells us
they're attempting to circumvent
mykolave as they look to drive west
towards odessa
more from odessa later on in the
programme
but as as the mod concludes russia is
certainly paying a high price as it
pushes across the country the ukrainian
armed forces in the mod's assessment
offering staunch resistance with an
overview of the latest developments
skies greg marlon has our first report
there is little choice for many in
ukraine but to make this journey fleeing
their homes as the shelling continues in
the hope of finding safe haven in a
place like bilirodka
they pack up whatever they can the lucky
ones to make it through one of the
humanitarian corridors
out of the terror of the fighting in
towns near the capital kiev
yesterday
we
go
with a russian
russian army
through the um through the park
where there are
russian soldiers or which is
which
killed people
and the scale of this exodus is
astonishing
this is the fourth day we have organised
such a headquarters here
in four days more than twenty five
thousand people have left mostly from
the jottemere direction
it's urpin booker
ostomel
today we went to borodianca nimachevo
are waiting for the buses with our
people from there
and the russian bombardment continues to
be focused on the population centers as
throughout this war satellite images
continue to tell a chilling story fires
burning apartment buildings destroyed
this is zelenskivo street in mariopol
before the shelling
and after
whatever the debate about the
effectiveness of the russian assault the
destruction of sites like this hospital
is evident in the city of malitapol
where the mayor was detained by russian
forces on friday a new mayor has
reportedly been installed the city is
under russian control president
zielinski warned that russia would try
to impose its own choice of leader in
occupied territories
the invaders in the kersan region are
trying to repeat the notorious
experience of the formation of pseudo
republics blackmail local leaders put
pressure on deputies look for someone to
bribe
the us has announced it's sending
another 200 million dollars worth of
military equipment
russia's invasion
threatens
not just ukraine's democracy
it threatens democracy and security
across
europe
and by extension when democracy is
threatened anywhere
it threatens
us all
millions of ukrainians have already left
these children being treated for cancer
boarding a medical train over the border
in poland
none of them knowing exactly when
they'll ever be able to make that
journey home again greg milam sky news
let's get the latest now nick martin
joining us from odessa in southern
ukraine and from the polish capital
warsaw lisa holland at nick to you first
though
from your social media account uh it
sounds like you might have had a bit of
a troubling night air raid sirens going
off in odessa
yeah this morning
we woke up to the sound of uh aired
sirens neil which is a a reminder if
ever we needed one that uh the threat is
ever present here and
uh these aread sirens they go off for
about 10 minutes and
people have to take their own
precautions of course odessa knows
because it's bracing itself that an
attack is probably not too far away so
these air raid sirens we would expect to
become more and more frequent as that
day arrives
elsewhere of course there is evidence
that the russian military have their
sights set on the west of the country
there was a missile attack in the city
of lev which is very close to the polish
border in the early hours of this
morning reports suggest that eight
missiles rain down on the center for
international peacekeeping which is
particularly worrying because we know
that that place has been used for
by nato in the past and it's been used
by nato for training so a significant
target and would suggest that that's
probably the furthest west that the
russian military have gone in the 18
days of this conflict
kiev the capital is under on bombardment
the russian military is getting closer
and closer to the capital it really is
the last chance now for civilians to get
out of that city and as they get as
russian forces get closer and closer it
will become less about missiles rockets
and shells and more about hand-to-hand
street combat that is of course what
people have been preparing for there
there are pros and cons to that for the
russian military the ukrainians will be
on their own streets they'll be able to
fight more strategically but it will get
very very intense there the ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky says that
what russia are trying to do is
partition off you ukraine to make it
pseudo states of russia and he said the
people of ukraine will not allow that to
happen we spent some time again in
odessa yesterday following people as
they tried to prepare themselves we met
some
men who just joined up in the military
part of the territorial defense force
they told us that they were willing to
die for their country but this morning
calm blue skies but the air raid sirens
remind us that trouble isn't far away
it certainly isn't um well let's bring
lisa holland in uh speaking to us of
course from from warsaw in poland lisa
as the russians continue their advances
the russians take more territory the the
inevitability is more euchre more and
more ukraines will try to leave the
country and one dire route of course is
over the border into poland how much
more can the poll can the polish take
yes morning it's absolutely the key
question because ashore as night follows
day as nick was describing there the
more and more cities that come under
attack places which previously uh people
had gone to because they thought it was
some kind of sanctuary in the west of
the country and as the fighting
intensifies you're going to get more and
more refugees coming over the border um
i think the difficulty here in poland
and certainly when we were in the
mayor's office um back on thursday and
they were saying to us look we're just
about coping and we're close to being
overwhelmed that that moment surely will
come very very soon
i am sensing tensions kind of on the
ground between local officials city
officials who are saying look
everything's been done at a kind of
volunteer level we do need more
structure from central government more
organization
to bus people out to other cities other
places around poland because the capital
here warsaw is creaking at the seams uh
and also so it would seem the second
city krakow is also coming under intense
pressure now
i think it's kind of interesting when
you hear about uh people discussing new
schemes in the uk for people to take uh
refugees into their homes when actually
a few days ago we were talking to people
who'd taken refugees in and the children
have already started school like it
gives you a sense of just how much is
being done here but all of that just
really can't go on and on and on and on
when there is absolutely no sign of the
fighting on the ground coming to any
kind of conclusion anytime soon
uh lisa holland in warsaw thanks very
much indeed
well we were just discussing it there at
britons who opened their homes to
ukrainian refugees fleeing the war are
to receive 350 pounds a month from the
government as a thank you
under the new scheme people will have to
provide homes or a spare room for at
least six months rent free skies katie
barnfield reports on one family keen to
open their doors
so this is the room that we're able to
offer
double bed and a single bed on the floor
hannah and matt want their spare room to
become a sanctuary but ensuite bathroom
so we're thinking that a couple or a
couple and a child they plan to offer it
up for free to a family who have fled
the war in ukraine
it's a moral obligation i think for us
all here to be able to do something
we've got the space to do this
um yeah we've got a family we've got
children but
why would we refuse these people they're
in desperate need they're planning to
sign up for the government's new homes
for ukraine scheme which will allow
people to sponsor refugees to come and
stay with them even those with no family
ties to the uk
the government says people offering a
room or a whole property rent free will
get 350 pounds a month as a thank you
those with accommodation will be vetted
and ukrainian applicants will be
security checked and the offer must be
for a minimum of six months it's quite a
big commitment isn't it six months
minimum it is but then
six months kind of isn't a long time
either and
we would welcome people to our home for
longer than that because we recognize
the plight that they've come from the
government has been criticized for its
response to the ukrainian refugee crisis
but charities say they hope this new
scheme will help thousands more in just
a week we've seen seven and a half
thousand people say that they want to
open their homes to welcome refugees
it's still an uncapped program that
means if we can find a sponsor a family
can come so if
20 000 sponsors come forward then that's
20 000 families that's huge
a website for the scheme is due to
launch tomorrow so people like hannah
and matt can offer a safe place for
those who have left everything behind
katie barnfield sky news
let's return to russia's military
progress in ukraine the latest
intelligence briefing from the minister
of defense suggests that russian forces
are trying to surround the ukrainians in
the east of the country are there signs
that the tides may be turning in the
conflict uh joining us now sam cranny
evans research and analyst at the royal
united services institute sam great to
have you on this morning and i i do
wonder just how much time you're able to
spend on social media these days given
the profusion of armchair generals that
appear to have
suddenly
suddenly spawned on there but but what
is your assessment as things stand is
the momentum with the russians or with
the ukrainians
and
yeah i i spend a lot of time on social
media unfortunately because it's quite a
quick way to track things and what is
quite useful is that you can get several
different sources of maps showing the
russian advances
and i think it's clear that
across all available sources the
russians are moving forwards with their
advances and that
um you know it raises tricky questions
because the ukrainians have provided a
very good narrative
which seems to suggest they're winning
which is hopefully the case but the maps
seem to suggest different that you know
especially in the south
from crimea and the donbass lehansk
regions the russians are moving forward
quite effectively and that pace has
actually quickened in the last few days
does this mean that they've sorted out
the logistical problems that you know
brought to a halt that convoy that was
advancing on kiev
um
possibly
i mean it's it's quite hard to say you
know what
i i suspect there was more than one
issue creating a lot of these problems a
lack of planning a lack of
um communication and things like that
leading into it as well
so
i think as well there's a difference in
the troops so a lot of those uh north of
kiev were from the eastern military
district which is typically the
lowest readiness um the least capable of
the russian troops whereas in the south
it's a lot of the southern and western
military district that are russia's best
so we'd expect those to advance um
quicker than those from the eastern
military district if if that makes sense
are the russians essentially
anticipating that they will be occupying
ukraine for the foreseeable future
um i don't think they are i suspect they
came into this with a few different
plans one of them
uh seemed to be an initial rush to try
and seize kiev and end the war that way
but it seems that as a fallback they at
least are going to encircle the forces
in the uh anti-terrorist operation zone
which is what ukraine calls the lehanska
donetsk regions
and
and and create that
what putin referred to as
demilitarization so there's a
significant portion of the ukrainian
troops are in that that pocket in the
east
so by defeating them they potentially
give themselves grounds to end the
conflict because they can say they've
demilitarized ukraine so i don't i don't
think an occupation is
likely or um possible really for the
russian forces it would absorb a lot of
men
and they have you know security concerns
elsewhere that they need to attend to
what what sam do you then make of the
reports that uh vladimir putin vladimir
putin clearly dissatisfied with the way
in which the conflict has gone has
placed under house arrest the head of
the fsb various generals have been have
been moved from the post i mean do these
reports have credibility do you think
um
it's it's really hard to know what's
going on in the kremlin um
it's hard to know what assumptions
they're making and things like that and
there's a constant game of power and
politics at play there
but it is entirely possible that they
would have
footed the bill so to speak for for
what's happened so far it is
notionally the fsb's assessments that
would have guided the initial campaign
plan and concept of operations in
ukraine and it seemed that they were
quite
um rosy in their belief that ukrainians
would would you know
acquiesce to russian presence
and things like that but then at the
same time they are under pressure to
report um what their superiors want them
to report rather than what they see is
the truth on the ground and we we can
see there are some
uh leaked letters supposedly coming out
now indicating that the fsb was aware
that these assessments might not be um
100 accurate at the time they were
submitted so
yeah it makes sense that some of them
are kind of
you know in trouble now
sam
what is your assessment of exactly how
useful what what utility that has come
from the the assistance that nato and
others have been providing to the
ukrainians and you know we know that you
know
president biden has made it very very
clear you're not going to get a no-fly
zone you're not going to get boots on
the ground suspicion that there might be
special forces working in and around the
area but but in terms of the kit that we
have been providing
what effect has that had on the russian
military advance
is providing the ukrainians with
a good deal of what we would term
tactical lethality so they are quite
capable of destroying russian tanks and
russian armor
which is useful but
a conflict rests on the totality of the
battlefield right so everything that's
deployed working in unison together so
the ukrainians have had good successes
but what really matters is their ability
to impact the operational picture and
that will really come down to things
like their ability to
maintain their force levels maintain
effective fighting forces communication
command control and also their ability
to resist artillery barrages because
that's what we're going to see a lot
more of as as the fighting if the
fighting becomes more urban
uh the russian predominance in artillery
will really start to show and tell
itself
um sam just just a final question i'm
not going to ask you how you think that
this all might end because frankly you
know we're at such an early stage
perhaps that it would be impossible to
say but but i do wonder how you think
the conflict will go over the next
couple of days given what we're seeing
in terms of the russian advance on kiev
given what we're seeing in and around
odessa
i would expect a fairly methodical
approach from the russian forces
um
they
sort of are in it now and have to make
the best of the situation so i'd expect
them to
proceed more carefully
less judicious use of fires so
artillery fire and missile strikes
against targets
greater use of uavs as well if if the
russians are beginning to organize
and bringing their capabilities to bear
then this would sort of be the time to
do it and it would begin to mark an
inflection point um especially for the
ukrainian forces
sam cranny evans having the program this
morning really appreciate your time
thank you
let's take a quick look at some of the
other stories surrounding the crisis now
and boris johnson is to hold meetings
with leaders of the nordic and baltic
countries to discuss discuss the crisis
in ukraine the prime minister will host
a summit of the joint expeditionary
force in london to talk about what more
can be done to secure europe's position
against russia
and russia has targeted peppa pig in
retaliation for the economic sanctions
that have been imposed following the
ukrainian invasion a court has ruled
that the cartoon character's trademarks
can be used by russian businesses
without punishment
entertainment one which owns the rights
to the popular children's series had
taken legal action
against a russian entrepreneur who had
drawn his own version of peppa pig
still to come we have the sport with
jackie what we got for us peppa pig gets
everywhere i know she's great isn't she
i'm surprised that she's not at chelsea
um couldn't do what's job well maybe she
is
big day ahead in the premier league with
chelsea face newcastle united later on
but what fate awaits their owner roman
abramovich soon to be exodus and what
will his disqualification as a director
mean for the club we have more next
[Music]
welcome back humanitarian aid is set to
arrive in the besieged city of mario
paul today the ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky has already described
the complexity of the route into the
southeastern city
joining us now in the programme julia
campbell who herself has
family in mario paul julia
i'm really glad that you've been able to
come and talk to us this morning and i
do appreciate your time but this must be
a really
really difficult time for you just just
just tell us when when was the last time
you spoke to your family in mario paul
good morning thank you for having me
um today marks 11 days
and i haven't had any contact with
anyone from my family
so
which members of your family are are
still in the city at the moment so my
mom um is there in monroeville my aunt
my uncles my cousins my nieces
about 20 members of my family um they're
all there my brother-in-law and lots of
my friends that i used to go to school
with and
half of my life was there so a lot of a
lot of my friends and family
we understand of course that the
communications can often be difficult
into ukraine at the moment and
particularly cellular communications at
the same time
you must have real fears for their
safety right now given that the level of
the the russian onslaught
watching watching everything that is
happening seeing the videos and the
footage it's still it's difficult to
imagine that this is what they're having
to live through every single day of
their life 24 hours a day
um the shelling does not stop um it is
roughly from six in the morning until
six in the evening and then most of the
night as well so people do not get a
break
during the day to go and seek any food
any water and also they can't get any
rest at night because the shedding is
relentless
um and it is just absolutely
unimaginable how people can live in
those conditions for this long without
any outside help without any
supplies being delivered without any
food or water or medication entering the
city for over 13 days now whatever
they're eating whatever they're drinking
now is what they had left
it is minus seven at night um they have
no heating they have no water they have
no electricity
and they are collecting snow outside um
for drinking
well we hear from from president
zielinski that that the humanitarian
corridors will be used later today to
try and get aid into the city at the
same time
there's not much of the city that
remains is there i was just looking at
those pictures there um of the city
basically you know large swathes of it
have now been have now been raised to
the ground tell me a little bit about
mario paul the city that it was before
the russians came
um it was the most beautiful place um um
so so much effort has been put into
restoring it rebuilding it after the
situation um in 2014 and um it is a
beautiful seaside
city um with so much gorgeous
infrastructure there's it's a
multinational community with lots of
universities um you know
it was thriving it was just at the best
point of of its existence i think before
this started
oh it looks like we may well have lost
you there julia can you hear me
we have great huge greek community you
know there is um
um about
at this point there is about 100 people
um have been trapped uh in the
marupul um and they are turkish citizens
and they're seeking shelter in one of
the mosques in uh in maryland um so that
you know it it was a very very beautiful
city but now it has been completely
wiped out and there is really not much
left
and
you know watching my my school being
bombed and the university they went to
it just
i cannot comprehend that still
given what you are seeing and and of
course given that the lack of contact
that you've had with so many members of
your family and and indeed your friends
i'm wondering what your thoughts are
of vladimir putin and indeed the russian
people right now
oh i don't know where to begin
that that there isn't a little glimpse
of humanity
left i i i cannot believe that one
person can totally destroy a country and
kill civilians
at such a large scale because what he's
doing at the moment is is wiping away
all ukrainians whether he wants to have
ukraine without any ukrainians in it
that's that's what i'm seeing um as you
probably have heard um you know
president zielinski has announced that
um over 1300 troops have died since the
beginning of the war
however mario paul
itself
has lost nearly 1500 people if you think
about the numbers they're all civilians
1500 civilians have been killed in the
last 14 days
and marupo is is just fighting its own
battle because nobody is helping
the humanitarian corridors are not
working
humanitarian aid is not coming in um
there was an attempt sixth or seventh
attempt yesterday lost count um where
the humanitarian aid was due to arrive
from zapposia
and um
again ceasefire has not happened um it
has not been abided uh by the russian
troops and therefore they stay there
they are in between people at the moment
they are on the board of moonfall but
this time i think in a desperate plight
to help
they um they've been accompanied by the
members of the church and there is uh
one member of the
church community is in each of the
vehicles just to to see if that might
help um but to be honest at this stage i
don't believe that anything will stop
putting you know he's he's bombing
schools he's born in hospitals he's born
in maternity wards he's bombing churches
all the churches in ukraine have now
been
mainly
most of them have been destroyed and
this is where people are seeking shelter
because a lot of the homes have been
destroyed people are living in these
conditions in weather
as i said it's known it's about minus
seven every day and they there are no
windows left um the homes are barely
standing people are cooking outside and
they're collecting wood and they're
they're making fire to in order to melt
snow and and make some kind of whatever
they've got left because nothing is
being delivered to the city the
infrastructure everything everything
critical for the city the whole
infrastructure has been destroyed
and um they they don't get any break or
any help
and really i'm afraid we have to leave
it there but we i genuinely hope that
you get words and good news um of your
friends and family and mario paul very
very soon and julia campbell thank you
so much for joining us i really
appreciate it
now the ukrainian sisters diana and
ivana yestremska played in the first
round of the doubles competition at
indian wells on friday after having to
escape from the city of odessa following
russian's invasion of ukraine in fact
they hid in an underground car park for
two straight days diana joins me now and
thank you so much donna for joining us
this morning um
you've played fantastically well in leon
last week uh you've just played in
indian wells how are you managing to
concentrate on tennis when you've had to
flee your country and leave your mum and
dad
behind how have you done it
hi um
well it's very tough to describe exactly
how how i try to manage myself inside
and
how i'm trying to keep myself in balance
between thinking all the time about my
family about the ukraine
and about it will be competing at the
tournaments
uh last week in lyon you know i
i think the only thing why i really
played a good it's uh because i was
trying to play not just for myself but
also for my country
i i tried to show that i'm also fighting
for
for my country and um
it's pretty hard it's very hard and
i never been experienced um never been
experienced with that before
and um
you have to you have to
be
focused on your mattress you have to
be focused on the tournaments because
you need to think about the future
and ask my father it's only before we
were leaving and crossing the border
that
you guys have to stay close to each
other you have to support each other you
have to
you have to build your future because
you don't know how this work gonna end
and uh you need to look for your calls
and it was very difficult to clock to
cross the border
because you don't know when you're gonna
see your parents for the next time
so have you spoken have you spoken to
your parents a lot are you in contact
with them are they okay
uh well we talk with my parents yes
but we don't do it too often because
sometimes
they have to be in the parking sometimes
they have to be the underground so it's
pretty tough to talk to each other but
uh when we have the opportunity we try
to talk as much as possible and are you
homeless now diana do you have somewhere
to go because
i know that you're on the tour so you're
going from country to country but you
can't go home in between where where
will you stay what is the long-term plan
well that's a good question uh but for
now we don't have any exactly place and
base where we're gonna stay in practice
uh
for now we're just moving from one
tournament to other tournament
and uh we need to think about the base
because i don't know when we're gonna be
back to ukraine
and i don't know when everything is
gonna be finished but uh for now we're
gonna stay in usa and then um
then we're gonna go for some other
tournaments
okay okay and uh yeah we have to we have
to think and plan it yeah okay it's a
very very awful situation and you know
our hearts go out to you but we had some
very nice news um from ukraine in the
last couple of days and i don't know if
you personally know leonid
stanislavski he is the world's oldest
tennis player
he lived in hakeev
and he has managed to get out of the
flat he's lived in for 60 years
with a suitcase and his tennis racket
and he's got to safety in poland
um
does this sort of sum up the ukrainian
spirit this never give up
even if you're 98.
well i yeah he's very popular in ukraine
and on march he will be 19 years old and
what i know is that um
he really wanted to play at the usa at
the world championship in early may
but now i guess it's almost impossible
and about this period i think all the
ukrainians people are has
a very strong spirit and for what they
make for standing for ukraine fighting
over there not just for themselves but
for the families for the
civilians for everybody for the country
i think that's an amazing spirit that
ukrainians has they're every person is a
hero right now there
and um
i know that um
i know that he he's he entered the uh
the junior's book of the records as the
oldest tennis player
and uh he was in the second uh world war
and uh i guess he was collecting the
aircrafts
so i don't know what he what he had what
he has to have in his mind about
everything that is going on now
but um
i think he's i think he's just like you
i think he's just like you he's
devastated
and he can't believe
that in 2022 this is happening that's
what he said listen i'm so sorry we're
out of time but you know we wish you all
the luck in the world
and to your younger sister as well
you're doing a great job keep going keep
playing well
and and stay safe and and you know keep
in contact with your mum and dad diana
thank you so much
thank you
stick with us after the break we'll take
you through the papers once again
[Music]
so
welcome back uh time for a final run
through the papers today we're joined by
the broadcaster pete price and the
author and broadcaster envelope good to
see you again guys um emma it's your
choice first and it's the story on the
front of the mail on sunday the idea
that we could be seizing the mansions of
the oligarchs to put up refugees it's an
interesting one this i mean two and a
half million refugees these mega
mansions won't cover it but at the same
time it's a pretty decent statement of
intent
yeah so this is michael gove our
leveling up secretary who's had this fab
idea to seize the homes of these
multi-million pound oligarchs who have
homes as we know all over london and the
southeast huge great big mansions um
apparently he's been arguing
passionately in cabinet for um
for this to happen but many senior
tories many people in the treasury in
the foreign office are saying this is
completely legally unworkable
um and
you know frankly i think it's i think
it's silly i think it's preposterous
because i think we need to be focusing
on
actually serious and compassionate
proposals for helping people come to the
country rather than um these sort of pie
in the sky ideas about seizing their
seizing their mansions legally it's not
workable neil it's not going to happen
i mean part of the problem of course is
that we don't know who owns the things
given that the government still hasn't
moved forward in the promise it made a
couple of years ago to stop overseas
companies being able to to own
properties you know places like british
virgin islands and pete let's let's go
to your your story though on page seven
of the of the sunday mirror
these these poor multi-millionaire
footballers at chelsea they must be
really struggling at the moment
i love this story it's fantastic they're
giving um chelsea 20 000 pound uh limits
for away games because of the sanctions
on obama vic and what i love is they're
saying to the players sorry guys it's
now budget hotels
budget flights
no more private flights no more
five-star hotels and what i love about
it is this might bring us back to
football come on lads back to the real
world meet real people and start playing
football like the old days
pete pete was about that far away from
saying jumpers for goal posts a second
ago so let's move on emma to your story
instead um in the times this one and
it's glossy magazines are pivoting to
wars somehow explain this one to me
they're pivoting towards so this is
magazines like um elle and vogue and
marry claire in ukraine they've been
offering their readers tips on giving
birth in a war zone
how not to damage your fake nails uh
when you're handling a weapon
um eating healthily despite you know
mass shortages in all the supermarkets
so they're sort of pivoting to war in
that they're giving lifestyle and beauty
tips to their readers during this time
of crisis
not sure whether i whether i think this
is completely crazy or actually you know
fair enough they need to they need to
publish their magazine they need to
reflect what readers are going through
yeah it's interesting because know every
organization every corporate entity is
now having to take a position on ukraine
so why not marry a marry claire or
graziana um pete let's let let's go to
your story in the again in sunday mirror
and page 16 this time
i'm struggling with this one the prime
minister rolling back on the ban on big
game hunting
yeah i'm struggling with this as well
i'm glad you said that because it is
terrible uh they say that they put it um
to one side now because of the ukraine
war that i understand but don't dismiss
this
but slaughtering of these beautiful
animals makes me so angry and for people
to bring trophies back like lions heads
and and zebra skins is dreadful so fine
uh put it to one side but don't dismiss
it do not dismiss it we've got to save
the world and these beautiful animals
have done nothing how these people have
these monstrous trophies in the house i
will never ever understand as long as i
live on this earth yeah i'm with you on
that one pete the government spokesman
saying that the government is committed
to strengthening animal welfare
standards we'll wait and see um emma
take us to your story in the express and
it's uh what's it about the queen
slightly more joyful um story on which
to end this is um how the uk is planning
to mark the queen's jubilee
but not only the uk across the us and
canada too they're all sorts of there's
going to be our obviously our extra bank
holiday in the first weekend in june and
then there are going to be street
parties there's going to be miniature
trooping of the colors with sort of baby
toy soldiers and things like that and
then on an official level there's going
to be the queen's birthday parade
there's a jubilee pageant a platinum
jubilee pageant
um obviously the raf fly past and a
party at the palace so it is something
to look forward to obviously the queen
hasn't been well and we've had you know
terrible terrible views for for months
now but this is something i think that
should hopefully lift the country um uh
in the start of june as we come into the
summer indeed um and pete your final
story
you can tell i've just seen what it is
tell us you're you're talking about
crafts are you or is it just doggies
getting getting pampered it looks good
anyway it's a good picture story
it's it crosses back which is great
because there's millions of dog owners
uh but we've got some wild and wonderful
looking dogs these ones with lions means
um i'd like dogs to start looking like
dogs again please that's a
dog and the best part of watching croft
is when the dogs don't perform just look
at the owners faces with the stubborn
little dogs i love this story to lighten
sunday morning
i thank you both for your contributions
to today's edition of when this were all
fields uh p emma lovely to have you both
on the program this morning great
contributions as always we'll see you
very very soon
i bet you can stay exactly where you are
after the break the latest from ukraine
as russian forces edge ever closer to
kiev
[Music]
[Music]
you